now it seems like a long period of time
today I'm identifying houses of worship
churches synagogues and mosques as
essential places that provide essential
services some governors have deemed to
liquor stores and abortion clinics is
essential but have left our churches and
other houses of worship it's now right
so I'm correcting this injustice and
calling houses of worship essential no
fatty crystal Allah Delevingne Sonja not
a vero no lose a stability territory
kappa turismo heed RT dare instituto
superior de Selita deacon okay in
levantus a we're gonna taper chain toe
so no more OT penalty photo da as a
cement a dotty
this equation if we dishonor la villita
miserable psychology Damania Schiavoni
generally been Osceola control epoch
Rossio element Sonia control a specific
SEO D cultural false Illuminati is a
little Yanni event each equilibar see
yourself razorba safety so no more seed
in fart-o become chlorophyll no Rosie
Amelie billionaire Italia no Rosie
Amelie
that H is really functional TC a dot a
numerical so luckily it's filled with
green or or a Pharisee no
develop residence or amorous in italia
windy severe episode a deacon or Davi
Rosa no Navy no human opener is a yari
importer or dictatorial cosine so Reedy
Colo and I say do we need to still
shelter in place our answer is
emphatically no Salam aleikum greetings
a piece how are you guys doing I have
two incredible gifts with me
ETA's coming up ramadan is ending and it
seems like we got some good news today
I'm buying houses of worship churches
synagogues and mosques as essential
places that provide essential services I
want to share with our guests to see
what they're thinking let me introduce
my guests we got dr. Schiff aloo Kareem
Zaid how are you an imam Issa how are
you doing brothers I'm good how are you
doing good hummed in law so let's get
right into it it was it was really
interesting to see I don't know if you
guys have seen the video where you have
President Trump
bringing into effect
I believe it's immediately that he was
commenting on how you had certain
essential businesses that were open one
was the alcohol shops and the abortion
clinics some governors have deemed
liquor stores and abortion clinics as
essential but have left our churches and
other houses of worship it's now right
so I'm correcting this injustice and
calling houses of worship essential now
what was really interesting there to see
was that the houses of worship that he
actually classified them as essential
now so it's interesting right before Eid
this comes about today did you guys see
this and what are your thoughts on that
subhanAllah our sister in the office at
TMCC would your permission brothers I
don't know I jumped on this you know my
brother I shouldn't have done that but
you know that's the problem with a man's
like me you know we love the microphones
yeah so so far along with when my sister
in the office
office manager you know send me the
video and I lost it I was amazed I was
amazed at the defiance of our president
president Trump you know on behalf of
the houses of worship I'm puzzled
wallahi puzzled by the fact that I go to
this Cusco this Walmart these Kmart and
everybody is having life and when it
comes to Allah and dealing with Allah no
no no no be careful be careful don't I
mean you're risking your life for the
life of this world
I mean subhanAllah there is a hadith out
there three individuals they have an
insurance policy
the hadith I believe he a new manager if
I'm not mistaken one of them went out of
his house to go to the Masjid of course
one of them going to Hajj and one of
them goes to do jihad justified you had
in the cause of Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
three individuals they have insurance
policy imagine the prophet salaallah
alayhi wasalam Eddie mentioned one of
them going to the Masjid so now we risk
in our lives go into the Walmart going
to old dunya our outlets outlets and
when it comes to the Masjid we cannot
use what they used out there for the
world yes they said we have to seek the
means tie your camel we believe in that
hundred percent but we cannot also use
these measures in order to open our
masajid the most beloved places to Allah
in earth in an authentic hadith the
Prophet sallallaahu re wa salim says a
hub Boubacar & leahey fill out the in a
while Messiah the most beloved places to
Allah in earth are the Messiah we cannot
put some extra effort to organize our
congregation there meanwhile
I'm sorry man you got me going on this
and I don't want to start with this but
but this is how I feel this is how I
feel quite frankly well lie well why
this is how I feel that some people are
happy that their Messiah door closed
well I am getting that completion Eddie
that some people are happy that they are
closing the Messiah and handle a we have
a reason now not to go to the Masjid
because we used to feel guilty all the
time for not going to the Masjid
alhamdulillah we can go to sleep now
because we didn't have to go to the
Masjid yes I am
I'm sorry I'm gonna stop everything for
me otherwise I'm gonna keep going
what do you well I think it's worth
mentioning that when it comes to Trump
is this really not shouldn't be a shock
to any of us you have to understand his
primary support in this country is
Zionist evangelical Christians and
they've been making a lot of noise about
not being able to go to church and so
it's my estimation and of course along
who's best that he's just catering to
them and he can't come out and say oh
well only churches can be open he has to
also say synagogues and temples and
mosques I you know I think if he could
get away with it he probably would just
say churches but just because of the the
nature of his office and he's
Constitution if you watch the video
carefully it took him part of a second
and I hope exactly he hesitates before
his laws a second he mentioned right
away straightforward churches synagogues
and mosques should I say that should I
say that shouldn't I say we know that
we're assuming actually the people know
I think when you have now you really
have people who are concerned some
people who are legitimately concerned
that they haven't seen the science which
there are many scientists there are
virologist there are experts they're not
really on the mainstream news but there
are people who are saying that you have
a very low percentage one less than 1%
chance of anything unless you have
underlining health issues unless you're
extremely up in age etc so how do you
balance it out how do you balance it out
where you're also tying the camel and
you're also trying to protect that life
but at the same time you are able to go
to the house of worship the house is
gonna cost it a lot I think it's
important for us to understand that just
like on 911 and just like any of these
you know
emergency situations that happen what
happens to the majority of people is
they get in a state of fear and when
you're in a state of fear you can't
think properly your your your intellect
does not operate the way it's supposed
to because you're you're in
fight-or-flight mode and just like on
911 and just like with this pandemic
crisis people over reacted and there
wasn't any lot of real science out yet
about what this was and what it was
going to do I saw videos on YouTube of
doctors telling just ridiculous advice
like like that this can stay on a
surface for three weeks guys a virus is
not a living thing it's not a bacteria
it's not a it only exists inside of your
cell okay so your cell has to be alive
and then the bacteria has to be inside
of that but a virus is not a living
thing okay you can think of it like a
code that gets into your cell and starts
telling it to do something else it's not
it's not a living being so they were
saying oh it survives on a surface for
three weeks and and it can survive in
the air and it can be passed at six feet
ten feet
thirteen feet you know and and and then
at one week the CDC would contradict
itself and say okay well we need to wear
a mask so we don't need to wear masks
and then a week later they would say
well it's not as contagious that used to
be what was happening is that gradually
we were learning more and more and more
while this process in full unfolded but
their initial reaction was an
overreaction in reality like you said
Eddie that the vast overwhelming
majority of
people who get this will have no
symptoms zero symptoms especially if
you're a young child or a teenager but
if you're elderly and I mean seriously
elderly like 70 late 70s 80s you have a
compromised immune system because of
pre-existing conditions then just like
with any virus whether it's the flu or
chickenpox or anything that you can get
from any time of year especially in the
winter time yes you should take extra
precautions but what we didn't need to
do is what I've seen these massages
doing as of late which is and I can
share if you allow me to share my screen
I'll show you some of the silliness but
the massage it with people praying in
salat with six feet gaps between them
everyone has to wear a mask in order to
come in the building you have to bring
your own prayer rug some massage it even
making it where you have to sign a form
to apply to go to Jamaa and the reason
they want your form is so that if
someone comes to the message who's sick
that day they can basically contact
trace you meaning you were there the
same day there were and now you have to
be quarantined for two weeks you know I
mean this this is absurd and this is
this is all you know you know people
changing the religion and then these
houses are Lilla therefore all lost
depend on with alle like you and i don't
have the right to start you know
obligating on our people in the messiah
jude to do these unnecessary things take
regular precautions that you would with
the flu or anything else you know go and
go to the mustachioed pray don't go if
you're sick which is by the way the
guidance of our prophets alive islam is
that if you're sick don't come to the
masjid this is not something new or
unheard of make booboo wash your hands
like muslims normally do but you know
the the overreaction i think people are
starting to sober up to now and allah
knows best
yeah brother a so just just to to let
you know that
the six feet or the three feet are
really a requirement by law meaning if
they come in and they find out that you
are not implementing these you will be
fine by the state thank you for bringing
that up
yes it is not something that we
voluntarily wants to do you know I want
to tell you something
I know officially you know I observed
the rules and then I started having only
ten people at the beginning of Ramadan
wearing masks it may be three feet apart
and then the city found out you know
some Muslims actually Muslims
organizations actually complained to the
city and we received that email saying
that guys if you continue doing that
we're gonna shut you down completely
even though we were actually observing
the you know the the procedures and
later on we we have to close the Masjid
for almost 10 10 nights of ramadan and
we finally get a word from the city just
yesterday and they are telling us that
these are the procedures which you have
to follow and if we send people to check
on you and you are in violation likewise
we're gonna shut you down so what we
need to be careful when we say that
we're changing the religion no but we
have to do that here's the here's a you
bring up a good point and I'm thank you
for mentioning that you are absolutely
right in most cases there was a legal
obligation on many of the churches
synagogues and mosques throughout the
country to implement these rules now
here's the problem with it number one is
that the government does not have the
right to do that to you Asma Sajid
other organizations throughout the
country and I came out by the way in
March online about this was as soon as
all this lockdown stuff started the
churches in my state of North Carolina
actually fought this and they got a
court order against the governor of our
state to where now he has absolutely no
right to dictate any of these rules to
us the problem is that the Muslim
community and I have to give credit to
the Christians where credit is due
we're not standing up for our
constitutional rights and and another
point to be aware of is that if if the
governments of the areas that were in
imposed these rules on this then it's on
them on the day of judgment if they if
they shut our massage it down or they
threaten to find so they do any of those
things then on the day of judgment we
have an excuse with a lost offender with
Allah but for us to just give up not
even I mean we have Muslims in this
country right now Sheikh was eight that
go out in the streets arm an arm with
cross-dressing homosexuals to to defend
their rights in the street but our own
religious rights to prep
you
acting arm trailer brothel worker due to
to implement basic things in the Sunnah
like the Prophet said don't leave gaps
because the Shaitaan will come in
between them for sure we don't even
stand up for our rights and and and
that's why I'm really I'm thankful and I
have to just sometimes blessings coming
from places that you don't expect that
the Christians in my state stood up
against our government and we said that
absolutely you're not gonna tell us how
many people we can have or what they
have to do if we want to do those things
ourselves by our own volition then we'll
do them and and and and maybe you didn't
know about this that's why I began it
but you you and I have a constitutional
right that we have to stand up for if we
don't stand up for it no one's gonna do
it for us in this case the Christians
did it for us in my state but the
Muslims are just sitting back like
lemmings just doing exactly what we're
told and not even questioning wait do
you have the right to tell us when I
open the Masjid for limited number of
people because they told us you cannot
have more than 10 people and then the
Muslims turned you in right yeah yeah we
have an organization here in Colorado
called leadership organization
leadership they sent an email to the
city to the health department and they
are killing the city Wow
please announce our names we wanna stay
anonymous weed we are defending the
rights of America and these guys are
violating the right imagine those are
Muslims just to show you that Muslims
themselves are happy to close the
message my state at my local masjid we
have never changed anything since the
time this all started we have continued
to have Jim Moore on we never put gaps
between people no one was required to
wear a mask nothing we've never changed
anything hold on hold on if someone's
being sensible and saying look maybe you
guys are being unsensible because the
model is that stay home stay lives and
that goes right in in line with the Deen
with Islam because Islam is about
preserving life so now what gives you
guys to rights if we're trying to stay
home and
they save lives and you guys are being
irresponsible how would you address that
a Simon a good debt
yes so you bring up a perfectly valid
point whenever there is grave danger to
a person right you've been given you
know there's a bear in the message for
example right you don't go into the mess
shouldn't pray because there's a bear in
there right and bears are not going to
be very friendly to human beings when
they're wild animals especially with
sharp teeth and claws okay but we have a
directive in our faith okay that
whenever a fasiq person comes to us with
any news Fatiha baya Anu Allah says
verify it these same people who lied
through their teeth on 9/11 and said
that planes hit towers and calls them to
crumble into dust when anybody with half
a brain cell almost 20 years later can
tell that this was a controlled
demolition and have continued to lie
about Muslims non-stop left and right
wing media for years now I'm not gonna
just believe anything they come out and
tell me and that applies to the same
government officials I'm gonna question
immediately any advice they give me and
the good news is that for anyone who
wanted to during since the beginning of
when the started until this day there
are plenty of good places you can go to
find quality authentic information about
the reality of the situation which is
that the majority of what's been
happening has been a complete over
reaction complete overreaction and that
yes while there is a danger the danger
is minimal to most people and it's and
to say that because there's any danger
at all we're going to shut the entire
economy down shut the doors of massage
and churches and synagogues is an
overreaction it's it's going well beyond
what's necessary ok if people want to
come
to the massager with masks on or
whatever they want to you know brand
Paul wants to stay at home because he's
80 your grandma has diabetes or whatever
you know these people have valid Shetty
excuses anyway you know but to start
implementing these new rules and once
again without with all due respect to
Imam Kareem because he didn't maybe know
about some of these things but and maybe
many people in the Muslim community
don't that's why I'm I'm speaking about
them you know but we have to be very
careful about how far we take these
things and and what's happened is that
we've been made to feel like every human
being is weaponized that every human
being is a potential threat to my life
you know I would do the grocery store
and they implement this social
distancing thing but they at first they
didn't have the little X's marked out
right so I would come and get in line
like normal and this people would turn
around and look at me like sure but I'll
do respect and you you know back up a
few more feet and it's like whoa you
know sorry I didn't know you know but
but that's how it was I'm I'm now a
potential threat to their life just like
Muslims were painted as a potential
threat to everyone's life after 9/11 now
everyone has been made to feel that way
about everyone else you have people in
their own houses quarantine from their
husband and their wife and their
children this has a profoundly negative
psychological effect and the last point
I'll make is that quarantine yourself
from viruses is actually the opposite of
what you should be doing let me explain
it decreases your immune system
you can't build an immune system by if
someone has a reduced immune system you
you hide them away because they can't
build the immune system if you have a
normal functioning immune system you
need in
action of course they aren't but that's
that's from media telling them to babies
when they're first born have very little
immune system but because they crawl
around on the ground they put their
hands in their mouths they taste
everything they get a lot of germs and
bacteria and viruses and themselves
their immune system which Allah created
to be extremely powerful and effective
against all of the threats that are out
there starts to build itself but when
you stick yourself in a bubble where
you've covered yourself and hand
sanitizer you don't touch people you
don't touch anything you don't go
outside and get vitamin D you know
you're not exercising your you're
destroying your immune system so that
when you when you finally do go back out
into the real world you've now exposed
yourself by having an extremely weak
immune system to getting just about
anything so and Dada and this is by the
way I'm not speaking this from from my
desires or what I wish things were these
are actual doctors that you can go
online and watch unfortunately a lot of
them have had their videos banned off of
YouTube or their Facebook accounts taken
off but the point I'm trying to make is
that these are legitimate doctors just
like the other legitimate doctors they
just happen to have a different opinion
about what's going on and we have to
consider that we have to question when
these let's be honest fasik news people
and fast government officials come out
and try to tell us information we can
say okay well thank you very much I'll
take a look at it myself you know
and I'll look at it and I'll examine it
and I'll do everything else like my
religion teaches me to do and then I'll
come to a conclusion and then if I want
to implement certain rules for myself my
family in my community will do that by
our own volition but you mister
government you don't have the right to
tell me what I'm gonna do and that's
something that we'd have to stand up for
and I'll end there Jay what do you have
to say about some of the things he said
and then there are two sides to the
issue Eddie and I I think we are a
low-low biding citizens
Muslims should be little biding citizen
yes law-abiding I understand exactly
where brother ISA is coming from I was
not made aware that you actually could
defy these lockdowns anonymous added or
or these procedures that you can
actually go to court and and tell them
you can do that you cannot impose this
on me this is for me and I'm glad
Christians did it you see so we have to
fulfill our covenants once it comes to
the laws otherwise find the legal ways
to defy that to say no to that
like they done in North Carolina and in
the state were said ASA is now the other
side
is the psychological side which is the
excessive field and I agree with brother
ace a hundred percent that this whole
deal of covet 19 is utilized for other
agendas out there Allah knows what they
are yes it has a presence but like I'm
gonna risk my life to go to the bank to
cash a check I'm gonna risk my life to
go to Walmart to buy a garment weight or
Superfresh or whatever it is to buy food
to eat if I'm driving on the highway I'm
risking my life there is always a chance
for me to die now why not that's where I
really have an issue why not use the
houses of Allah and I think this is
weird
President Trump today came out you guys
opened the liquor stores you guys opened
the Porsche the apportion the shops
where people go on and kill their
children you open all of the I know ASA
I'm 100% I know that he was not
defending a messiah he was defending his
his white guys I know that I I know that
but I am a white guy you know in a way
of what I'm trying to say is I know what
he's trying to do but that's the
beautiful thing about this country
Islam has to be included I know he was
not doing it and this is how a Christian
he sees he is voicing out the Christians
meanwhile Muslims Muslims are happy that
the Messiah door closed
well lie we have a guy in Egypt who runs
the Messiah dear the way that he talks
he's so happy that no masajid are open
that I mean they're the minister of its
called something like that to the extent
that one of the table in Egypt Medora
and he said oh Allah give us a a Muslim
minister and he's a man I'm a minister
of Islamic Affairs it's called
endowments likewise well I I have this
feeling that the people who are managing
the Messiah the people who have a say
about opening and closing the Messiah
they are happy that the messages are
closed because themselves you hardly see
them in the Messiah you hardly see them
in the Messiah and that's where my heart
aches Eddie that's where my heart aches
listen there is a potential threat in
everything that we do what is the world
here with no threat risk risk there is a
risk in everything if I Drive in the
highway there is a risk huh
I want to share this if you allow me in
a minute I read that story I saw which
is very interesting a judge of news '
well hi judge if news of a shock of the
you know a judge was a tyrant who killed
a lot of companions he
kill double lightness away enough the
first newborn in Islam the first born
Muslim child in Islam the son of asthma
remember as Matt when she used to go and
deliver the food in the cave so Abu
Buckland and Allah she was pregnant
that's them when she migrated she
delivered Abdul I imagine this man
killed killed Abdul liveness ye might
know Homer the son of Ramadan hot top
I'm gonna make it quick he ready
a judge cold for him come to me a blood
number was blinded he he lost his vision
was the end of his life so he took his
son Sally modem Sal so they went to a
jet they arrived they found al-hajjaj
[Music]
very angry and upset at a man in his
place she immediately called Annie son
[Music]
[Music]
it was so hot Iijima ahh did you bring
fragile Anjana he said yes so he said to
him who thought he could run away he go
run away flee so sad him came back to
this tyrant killer and the tyrant asked
him a judge if named Yusuf what did you
do with him yes Alan he said listen I
let him go so he got angry and he said
why he said my father right here
marinated is to me that he heard the
messenger of allah sallallahu alayhi
wasallam says whoever braze phagon in
Jumeirah feed-in Mithila is under the
protection of Allah how do you want me
to kill someone who's under the
protection of Allah imagine the tyrant
raised his head said he got me you got
me that's a good one again and I'm not
eating the whole story why you know
people live with the Alliance otaku rely
on someone Allah subhana wa tada yes
there are the risk factor is there in
everything that we do and listen we
entertain this for a while we
entertained it for a while and the
numbers are already decreasing
alhamdulillah and other places related
to our lives are opening up Linux people
businesses are back it's as crowded why
the house is a fortune why them I said
it why why
yeah and that's where I eat my heart
aches I think those are just relevant
questions because you have a lot of time
we share some more some more interesting
effects what you guys don't want to get
your feedback the UN it's now estimating
that 130 million people will suffer from
starvation this year because of the
economic shutdown across the world
suicide hotlines are reporting call
volumes up nearly 900 percent during
this lockdown one point four million
people in the u.s. attempted suicide and
forty seven thousand were successful in
2019 now tens of millions in the US are
now unemployed there are an infinite
number of studies of the psychological
and health issues an ultimate increase
in death rates associated with the
unemployment and poverty
now that the antibody testing is more
prevalent they are showing a lot more
people have had the covert 19 than
previously thought and could mean that
the mortality rate is actually closer to
0.1% to 0.2% not the the initially known
what was propagated 2% originally so now
when you guys see this when you see that
the the cure is being worse than the
disease how does how do the scholars now
look at this and when you see people who
are
not necessarily because you have the
mainstream and then you have others who
are experts also we were told to go to
the experts so when you look at some of
these facts you have saw now people
dying from suicide more people you have
a whole group of people are not going to
be able to support their families
because they've lost jobs and then you
have other experts as saying that like
like what which no one's talking about
strengthening the gift that Allah has
given us the immune system doctoring and
I just tweeted two patients from the car
outside because we're trying to keep
them away from our office and keep our
staff healthy so what we're seeing is
that our therapies are working we use a
combination of oral vitamins vitamin A C
D and iodine and then using nebulized
hydrogen peroxide and iodine if they're
a little bit worse and then we're using
IV vitamin c and IV peroxide and we are
so far treating over 100 patients all of
our patients are better dramatically
better
no one's hospitalized no one's been
ventilated and no one's died and so
we're seeing positive results with this
therapy you know I told my staff that
we've been practicing holistic medicine
for 25 years the first 24 years were
practice for something like this and we
were ready for this when we knew it was
coming and we knew the therapies were
going to work because we've treated
influenza will like illnesses for the
last 20 years and we treated them
successfully so there are therapies out
there that work we don't have to have
this fear level at 10 out of 10 you are
right on the money Dell and we need hurt
immunity and we need to get over this
and our therapies are working for our
patients it's it's a it's just it's
almost miraculous what we're seeing the
mortality rate is 0.1% almost now that
the numbers are increasing the science
is showing that's you know and many
experts are showing this not just us
making this stuff up does that change
things the fik ruling does it change
things now on the ground when scholars
look at this from a holistic the
primitive realistic a holistic view
rather than at the beginning it was just
panic you didn't know but now that the
facts are coming out do you really think
and give a new decision 100% I mean
you know would be packs coming out to
the extent that the conspiracy theories
in my opinion in the last two weeks have
been circulating regarding this covet
nineteen more than anything else which I
experienced before as major you know
[Music]
thing happening subhanAllah I read these
ratios that eighty-three thousand people
in the United States of America die
every year from drunk driving accidents
associated with drunk driving
I read that fit and that's the year 2014
I don't know if this number increased or
not with legalization of marijuana and
and across the states when I read that
at least fifty thousand Americans die
every year from influenza that Eagle of
influenza every year so what is the deal
with with with this that I I think this
thing is being manipulated I think there
is something wrong there and we got to
do something about it and alhamdulillah
we got our president who is voicing out
our voices as Muslim Imams he actually
said that
I trust the Imams I know them that they
we will you know follow the protocol
which the city imposes on us for now and
we find a way if it hopefully it's not
going to continue that we can defy like
they did in North Carolina with he says
but we shouldn't we shouldn't be
entertaining this anymore Eddie
we shouldn't be in this is
what what have some of the the other you
obviously know a lot of and friends and
you have other colleagues that are are
with you on certain committees of the
from Islamic scholars where they may be
questioned again because you yeah I want
to see so what did you have to say about
somebody just away from a little bit can
you hear me now we can yes he saw what
are your thoughts now we what are your
thoughts are some of these statistics
some of these numbers the data that's
showing up really new to me I mean I'm
what fully avoidable right but you go
the Tourette kalila law as a shake I was
eight said you know but it's the
percentage a rate of that happening is
so small right it's not like every time
you get in the car there's a one or two
percent risk that that might happen and
that's really the way we have to look at
this situation we have to now reassess
the information because we have to
remember that one of the things that
happen during this whole crisis is that
a lot of people and this is important
for your audience to note a lot of
people who entered hospitals who did not
have coronavirus were being labeled as
coronavirus because they had similar
symptoms of corona virus which by the
way are extremely vague in general dry
cough fever that could apply to so many
different illnesses but doctors were
actually being encouraged and this is
now mainstream information you don't
this is not a conspiracy theory or
somebody's wild opinion it's it's
documented fact that doctors were being
encouraged to label people with corona
virus who actually probably didn't have
it at all also something to be aware of
in some other countries that had higher
death
allegedly from this actually what would
happen is that someone who already had
for example a terminal illness like
stage four cancer or any other kind of
disease that was eventually going to in
their life anyway if they died but they
also happen to have corona virus they
would be labeled as a corona virus death
the corona virus didn't kill them it was
their stage 4 cancer that killed them
right but because they tested positive
for it they were being labeled as a
corona virus death what did that do is
it increased in both cases the numbers
of alleged cases and alleged death
counts which added to the fear and gave
the media all the weapon they needed to
keep you and I scared right but once
again if you just took a step back and
said okay let me assess the information
that's coming in and its accuracy and
look at the the real numbers is the
statistics and analyzed it to statistics
hamdullah I took a class in college
called mathematical models where we
analyze statistics that was one of the
main points of the college course and
you start to realize that computer
modeling and statistics can all be
manipulated it all depends on the data
and how its entered you only get out
what you put in and so a lot of these
so-called projections at the beginning
that came from these Rockefeller funded
organizations all over the world and
Bill Gates funded organizations all over
the world they came out with these
computer models that had these huge
graphs of millions of people were going
to die in the United States and Britain
right they were nothing but computer
projections they had no basis in reality
it was literally some scientists
somewhere plugging in numbers that they
chose and getting out a result and then
telling the whole public this is what's
going to happen when in reality it was
just a computer model it may it may
happen it may not happen but we have to
look at the data we have to go beyond
just the graph and look at how the graph
was produced what was the information
used to put into it and that's why it's
really important
we as believers have to be people who
think the core honestly come--it effect
alone for people who think we have to
just go beyond just regurgitating what
we're told on television what we're told
by other people who are repeating other
things they said even good by the way
and I say this good Muslim doctors with
with good hearts with PhDs and
everything they themselves in many cases
are just repeaters they're just
repeating what the CDC told them what
the who told them by the way the WHO
very interesting organization to look
into their current head from Ethiopia
five times call covering up malaria
being spread in his own country you know
not exactly the most trustworthy person
in the world in my opinion
but the the important thing to
understand here is that we're people who
step back and look at information and
assess it before we start making in my
opinion and you feel free to disagree
irrational decisions let me ask you guys
some legitimate concerns someone says
share tell us how can we manage this if
you go to Costco unlike the mustard
you're gonna be making such done so you
can't make sajdah technically you can if
you want it to cost what I mean such as
sugar maybe if you were happy about
something but but what I'm saying is
you're not going to pray in the masjid
so someone can pick up something from
the carpet
they also say you're gonna be having
people coming who are in there if you
put a requirement you'd say that you
can't come to the mustard unless you're
sixty under sixty or seventy and you
know a lot of times you can't even get a
lot of the elders to obey the rules
about parking not parking your
neighbor's parking lot or something like
that your shoes in the shoe rack or the
shoes on a shoe rack right so how would
you address these concerns that might
seem very legitimate we we at dollar toe
heat here in Colorado today
we got the go-ahead from the city that
we can actually open up they told us
certain procedures we implemented them
we buy the book they told us
more than ten people in one room so we
ended up you know dividing the rooms and
you know we we made shortened hook buzz
we did some accommodation we did some
accommodation we kept the distancing you
know I hope I knew this too like brother
ISA mentioned because I want to pray the
way the prophets of Lausanne and pray
that's my you know that's what we teach
that's what we spend time on letting
people know that we have to follow the
Sunnah so hopefully this will be left it
soon but what I want to say is brother
Eddie it's gonna take more work on the
side of the management would work on you
know boot some efforts boot some you
know some some resources in place yes
some people were unhappy to tell them
you can be congregating outside the
Masjid today you have to go home you
know they yelled at us sometimes it's
okay but what matters is I want the
house of Allah to be Hootie hooting
add-in Allah who and to for our youth
curavi has smooth imagine this the name
of Allah is being mentioned the Adhan is
being cooled the Akama is being made the
salah is being established you know so
people who are custodians of the masjid
must put the effort must put the
resources and they cannot just listen
tie your camel 100% tie your camel but
like I go really
I tell the brothers and the sisters like
you guru D at the bank to cash a check
or you will the sharp to buy some food
and they tell you stay here like those
will that brother Jason and the shut up
and and we will why not adhere to the
the system booth by the management
why do you file a key
you cannot violate the system of for the
ncover of a grocery store
why do you maybe that's where we we have
to treat our masajid
with respect and respect the leadership
of the Masjid so all of these have to
come in please be light either but the
solution is not to close the Masjid the
solution is not to shut down the Masjid
that's where I have an issue with
brother Eddy and FERC for Allah sake
Muslims stand up for your rights you
know don't take my advice that I gave
today is I'm telling you to go break the
law I didn't say that the law says you
have the right to practice your religion
the problem is that in a panic we all
fault that we were getting good advice
because we didn't remember the same
liars who lied to us 20 years ago are
gonna lie again in the future right they
have not proved they've never made tow
before the first lie right so we have no
reason to believe them this time but we
in a state of panic
thought we were receiving a lot of good
advice and so we thought we were doing
good things but in reality and
subhanAllah you know we have so many
Islamic legal organizations in this
country but care and mil feh and all of
these organizations we need to put them
to work you know in Colorado Sheikh Abu
Sayyaf you don't have the right yet like
we have in in North Carolina then take
them to court the same law in North
Carolina can apply in your land and
really that's a challenge I give to all
the Muslim leaders and Imams in this
country stand up for your right and and
once again no one's telling everyone to
go to the message it and start mingling
and kissing people on the lips and all
good no right we're not telling you to
go do ridiculous things we're telling
people that we should we as the the our
religious community should have the
right to dictate our own laws and rules
for our massagin and of course those
should be founded in the Quran and
Sunnah and that's that's what we should
be doing we have to stand up and say no
thank you mr. government
thank you health officials for your
advice we appreciate it we'll look at
the information and then we'll assess
how we want to deal with our communities
but we are not going to allow you to
implement on us things that are
unconstitutional and and what's
important understand is a lot of us that
didn't grow up here in United States we
come from countries where you don't have
the right to do that kind of thing there
really is no legal recourse for you to
get your your number one god-given
rights that Allah gave every human being
but your your also your your rights that
your government is supposed to uphold
for you and so a lot of us don't realize
that you can do that here but you can
you can stand up for your rights here
and it would be really a blessing and it
would it would put east in my heart to
see that a Muslim organization or Imam
or someone in this country you know took
that took the reins of that you know and
did just like the Christians did here
which I mean you know blessings like
like imam abu zaid was alluding to
blessings come from places you don't
expect sometimes you know I mean I mean
Trump may have his reasons for doing
what he's doing but it's benefiting us
and the Christians in this in my state
had their reasons for doing what they're
doing but we benefit from it
there is a hadith base out there which
says Allah gives victory will give
victory to this religion through the
wicked man roger-dodger yes how do you
we should be giving victory to our own
things yes really we should and and this
is this is this is tied directly to you
know levena call who rob boon allahu the
mustafar mu you know like we we have to
make a law or rob really and that's
that's what that means and then the
angels give you good news of the agenda
so how did the scholars how do they
determine because most of the time they
will point because allah o allah the
creator of heavens and earth says go to
the experts so there are there have been
organizations put in place that for the
well-being of humanity but then when
people look into this other experts in
other areas they
see that there are many conflicts of
interests they see that many like you
had gave an example of one individual
but you see corruption
you see fraud you see manipulation of
data then a lot of times you'll see
people uncover that there is an agenda a
lot of times so now how do the scholars
now if they point it towards an
institution and they found like for
example if the hadith comes to you and
this hadith has been fabricated right
we cannot still go off this hadith and
even the person is bringing it is not
allowed testimony or anything so if you
have if the scholars look at an
organization that's been known to lie to
manipulate fabricate and now we've been
looking and we've been changing and
making our decisions according to this
organization what do you do in this
situation shape well you know the
unenforced him the unfortunate fact we
don't have i mean body of dualists the
Luas we have across the blues are really
dear to validate a lot what rulers and
the people in authority are trying to
push on the people so in your left with
individual you know scholars people who
hate the time to you know to look into
the numbers look into the facts being
unbiased you see and they balance this
with that and they give a verdict now
how many people follow that individual
very few and that individual also
individual school that individual -
doesn't have the the info
[Music]
and to some extent in in many cases they
really validate what the leaders want
them to do the presidents and the Kings
and the Queens and all of that they have
also the law enforcement in the side
meaning if they in Egypt or example you
know they arrested some people some
Muslims we decided to hold her are we on
the rooftop of their houses imagine a
building where you have different people
living in apartment buildings okay guys
let's go to the rooftop they said be you
guys are defying the law because that
Minister said he can do that so what I'm
trying to say is people have to look for
the right people the right individual
and hopefully they will find the truth
someplace somewhere but we have waited I
think they did it we have given this Co
bed 19 the benefit of the doubt for long
for long and you know the frustration
that I saw on the face of President
Trump today represented me represented
my frustration that you're opening the
liquor store be apportioned clinics all
the Haram things all the dunya things
and when once it comes to the Masjid no
be careful you're gonna die if you go
pray that attitude of Muslims is bad and
I think I'm grateful to these Christians
out there who stood and made their
voices heard by the president I'm sure
not many Muslims also some Muslims also
maybe have spoken but this is where my
heart is really aching ad is not about
the fact we're here or there
is about a reality now that that that
thing is is is is taken out of context
totally to impose certain agendas on
people and some Muslim countries back in
the Muslim world that presidents and
those people they wanna kill Islam they
wanna make Islam die
you know they kill you go pray nobody is
allowed to sit in the message between
the salawa no lectures no talks so they
use all of this can this be can this be
because we take shaitan out of the mix a
lot of times when it comes to circular
things or these but can we see
potentially where I mean because
Shaitaan is hard at work using this also
and the Satanic forces to piggyback off
of this and to try to have more
roadblocks for people going to Masjid
and creating more confusion and dividing
a neighbor against neighbor and I mean
because a lot of times we don't look
deeper enough into and we think okay how
does shakedown have his hands and many
of these things is Shaitaan on hold when
it comes to things like this is he this
is off limits um well you you bring up a
really valid point I'll just briefly
answer it we have to understand that
that at this point in history brothers
and sisters in Islam and especially your
audience you need to wake up and realize
that we're living in a theaters Ahmet
you know the signs are all around you if
you just look the tall buildings being
built in the Arabian Peninsula and we
know that one of the greatest signs of a
theaters of men is a dead Joe the
Antichrist and his name in and of itself
describes exactly his his whole modus
operandi which is deception everything
about him is deception everything he
says will be a deception even he speaks
the truth it's only to reinforce his
lies and who is Dajjal and cook quartz
with his the shape on and we know that
from the authentic hadith that the shape
ons the the most prized shape on to a
blase is the one who divides up a
marriage you're right and so his his
number one concern is to atomize
humanity as much as possible to get you
away from people
to socially distance you from everyone
and the places where you gather to to to
get strength the dua during the Friday
khutba
has more power than your dua by itself
when the Imam is raising his hands and
everyone is saying I mean that's more it
has more power behind it more connection
to a lot spending with Allah than just
our individual EDA yeah you know so we
we have to recognize that that that no
matter what you think about this
situation you're absolutely right Eddie
and thank you for bringing it up the
Shaitaan is taking advantage of this
situation and at the jowl will take
advantage of this situation also I have
to leave brothers it is ma goat of time
here in North Carolina and you guys are
in the the Chicago and Denver areas so
you still have some time left of the day
I just want to say before I end and
leave which I apologize for having to
leave abruptly please brothers and
sisters in Islam if you disagree with
anything I or Eddie or or sheikh abu
zaid said today please do it in a
respectfully brotherly and sisterly way
this is Ramadan don't resort to
backbiting and slandering it's okay to
disagree with everything I said to not
even like it okay but let's all be
brothers and sisters about this I didn't
come on here today to speak a bunch of
ideas that I have in my head I've done
my research and you should do yours also
it is a it is a command in our religion
to do that so please you know don't
don't feel free to disagree with me but
let's be respectful about it especially
in the comment sections and and let's
not resort to backbiting and slandering
people well unless question for you
after you finish your thought oh well I
was just gonna make a dua on leaf I just
have one thing for you then you make
what do you advise people how do you do
your research because many a times
people are glued and getting their
research or their what they perceive as
correct information from mainstream
media how do you what are some good
resources when you're a critical thinker
to go outside of that box to investigate
to come to you know a better conclusion
or a better holistic perspective a good
place to start was the episode you did
of the Deen show with doctor
Butare which is here from North Carolina
it's good to go at least listen to what
he has to say
he also operates with a politician one
of the Kennedys I don't remember his
first name
Robert Kennedy jr. not another good
place to go and then from both of them
they'll give you more names and once
again you don't have to believe anything
they say but just listen to what they
have to say and go as says the
information you know and that's all you
have to do you don't you don't have to
believe anything I said today you know
go assess the information for yourself
don't just take everything I say or
anyone says with-with-with just total
acceptance go prove it to yourself that
that Bay you knew right Surpanakha low
home will be handy good when I should
have let you do that would be wonderful
it'd be nice when I can finally go
outside my state again and give a foot
bud so they come here so you still need
me okay so I mean we're just wrapping up
now so what is your advice it's it's it
was we started this off with what we
thought might be some good news that
right before Eid there's the good news
that the places of worship the place of
God Almighty the creator along will be
deemed as essential so now we've also
driven there's new data showing that the
threat is very very miniscule you are
much safer than you think and there are
a lot of experts out there that are
propagating this scientists you know
people of credibility you just have to
search for it is there so now what is
your advice it's Eid now it's coming
Ramadan is is over how do we perceive
this how do we take this do we go and
pray eat in a mustard what do we do
let me put it this way Eddie every
individual must make his own individual
judgment your level of anxiety your
level of fear
your level of especially if you're on
somebody with a compromising you know
immune system can a disease like
diabetes and and and these people it
does a higher risk so those are higher
risk people stay back that's fine
listen you can bring aid last night on
my show I explained to the people how to
brai eight III I think they produce like
a five minutes video how to pray eight
with your family at home you don't have
you don't have to do hopeless just lead
to Rakas after the sunrise is fifteen
minutes minutes after the Sun rises you
start from there
lead your family in the first raka you
do seven takbir not including the first
at birra
and the second raka you do five
Technorati
excluding the that we are coming up from
salud and you recite Fatiha and pull on
in each raka preferably Allah in the
first raka elvish a in the second Locker
stay home if this is gonna make you
comfortable but if you want to go out
deal
alhamdulillah rely upon Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala for laying your C minor in lemma
cuttable ah who let her do it I'm gonna
have AIT's a lot that without even
Corrado but I'm gonna also tie my camel
yes maybe there is a way to define
because this is laws that I have to
fulfill I'm gonna keep the distancing
even though that's not a sin asana I'm
gonna ask the brothers to wear masks I'm
gonna tie the camels I'm gonna ask them
please know you know congregation around
that the message just go home after work
I'm gonna tie the camel but I wanna
mention Allah his name in his house well
it only took moon relate that that while
he took a pill aha and I'm ahead of them
so that you can complete your fasting
and you go there and you say Allah what
for
la la la la la allah allahu akbar wa
lillahil hamd if we can get few people
few Muslims making this happen in our
massage it and not be afraid meanwhile
buying the camels I think that should be
the attitude of the leadership of the
massage it the attitude of the people
who go to the Masjid Eddy
wallah alum and Allah knows best
inshallah that seems like because we're
a moderate people we don't go to one
extreme or the other so you don't know
trying the camel
taking taking some proper measurements
but at the same time you want to worship
your Creator in his house in the house
of Allah how do you are just a couple
more questions how do you because you
often quote this hadith where the
prophet saw something had talked about
when there was a plague in a certain
area and paraphrasing they instructed to
stay out of that area and the other ones
not to come in so not to leave her to
come in
how are the mushrooms at this time where
there were there were those mush it's
closed at that time how was it know that
people went to the Masjid if you read
the books well lie if you read the
history I went back and I checked it the
people left their homes and spend the
time in the Masjid imagine this we hold
on hold on so they didn't abandon even
when we do the massage to make du'a that
during the plague at that time during
the plague at this time they went the
taco
buta in a mess a GD that's exactly and I
wait and I'm sure it wasn't considered
like here many are saying this is again
it's worse than a flu but that was
something that people were really dying
that fact I mean it was really nothing
it was a real we're really evening
fiddly we're giving were giving back
characteristics the descriptions of a
blade to this virus it's a virus not a
blade yeah because we have a hadith that
says this that Blake doesn't enter Mecca
and Medina and the people started
doubting that it's in Mecca and Medina
and how come you tell me no it is not a
Blake it's a virus but the people are
treating it like a Blake
people are treating it like a flea you
know what a plague is that that that you
taught somebody you dead a plague that's
totally different yes yes 25,000 people
died in a mosque and found a mosque and
this is one narration this time meaning
this is totally different I mean so
you're saying that this is like you
touch someone or you this is like body
parts but just like drop in dead this is
not right like here yeah we have given
there were three and they were still
going to the Masjid they because that's
a good place to die you know you know I
know some non-muslims may not you know I
like what you said people who are older
who have underlying health issue maybe
they want to quarantine themselves they
want to take care of themselves but you
have keeping it fair and balanced you
want to go to the house of Allah
what else did I want to ask you I wanted
to ask you before we leave I know we're
out of time but what other advice would
you give for people during this hysteria
burring whatever you want to call it
planned emic planned enemy but
ultimately it's all in the plans of the
creator of the heavens and earth god
almighty allah for people who are really
fearing this but they don't fear they
don't fear the consequence of not
praying five times a day they don't fear
the consequence of shutting down the
liquor stores even though you have some
Muslims who own liquor store it's
unfortunately but they fear this and
they fear more of institution or people
rather than fearing the injunctions of
God Almighty Allah what advice would you
have for them subhanAllah
make I think brothers and sisters in
Islam and I'm addressing you define your
goals in life if you think that you're
gonna have paradise on earth it will
never happen
this world Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
designed it to be a testing place not a
resting place the rest and comfort is in
general they asked the limb am ahmed
mohammed rahim allah mehta and a stirry
when when we rest
he said when we have our two feet in
jannah that's when you will rest now
brothers and sisters in islam we're
going to face more trials and
tribulations because what i frankly were
not in control as muslims of the media
of the orchestrated scheming out there
that is orchestrated scheming out there
to control the population we don't know
whole a lot about it you know we don't
know whole a lot about it were not even
part of it so we're still gonna face
more than that the only way you can face
this is the provision of Eman nos deal
they believe in Allah subhana wa tada
well AUC Vanna ulema cuttable ah Hulan
imagine you're living with their motto
slogan in front of you nothing can be
fool you unless Allah willed it for you
yes I'm gonna seek the means yes I'm
gonna try my camel but what if it
happens to me a B there is another world
that is gender how did okay I'm going
for that and that should be I'm hoping
that that should be my attitude I'm not
claiming that that's me I'm striving to
be like that and I have my shortcomings
and you know you do as well and
everybody but that should be your agenda
if this is I'll share this hadith with
you maybe at the very end of this which
really concludes the whole thing the
Prophet sallallahu alayhi wa sallam and
the hadith is authentic it's only man
eternity
is the narrator's whoever makes the heel
after his absolute and ultimate goal
ultimate goal objective aim man jihad al
hurriya ham ma look at this because this
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala will make him
see or her see himself herself rich
jalalahu he now who feel called me you
gonna see yourself rich even if you
don't have because the prophet
sallallaahu rusle mentioned that riches
is not about having so many assets or
bank accounts is about being content
with what you have play this is one what
a Gemini love and I am Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala will facilitate his life we will
make his life easy look at this what at
that would dunya what he around him this
world will come to him he's gonna get
this world because his focus is in the
Hereafter his focus is in the Hereafter
but look on the other side whoever
focuses in this world his interest its
goal higher aim is this world he's gonna
see himself almost fool needing jalalahu
[ __ ] Ahuva ena ena he always will see
himself who and he will be distracted
with this problem he has a lawsuit here
his wife is divorcing him here his
children are under drugs is he's big and
he will get only only from this world
what Allah root for him I think that
should be the attitude of a believer
towards what's to come and insha'Allah
Allah will save us and there would be a
light at the end of the tunnel maybe
later Allah we ask Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala to bring all of you brothers and
sisters in Islam out of that combat 19c
sound go back to the masajid
will
the houses of Allah in the middle my
said in a law human a mandible a human
ashes indeed those wood will those who
make the houses of a lot alive and those
who believe in Allah and the Hereafter
come on trust Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
meet Dora
yes seek the means try the camel nobody
said that nobody that we should
compromise that but we shouldn't have
banned him the houses of Allah and we
begin now
dwelling the worldly institutions and
entities make them busy and the houses
of Allah are empty because we were
afraid or afraid that's it Eddie that's
all I can say about that
thank you for them thank you very much
for sharing your thoughts with us and
it's very important I think that you
know because a lot of times it's easy to
toe the line and it's easy to be
mainstream but this troop is not always
there with with what we perceive coming
to us from from some of the mainstream
media and I ask people to put a lot of
the scientific studies and the data
that's out there a lot of the scientists
and doctors you can share it here in our
comments section and put it out there
because sometimes this gives some
release because when you get more of a
holistic picture you really know the
facts you know and and you go outside of
the mainstream you do your critical
thinking it also helps to bring some
relief and some confidence in your and
make you more informed and have a better
decision because if what kind of life is
it if we're just you're actually more
people getting sick from just the fear
and and and and and worry and stress and
you kill yourself from that not even
from kovat and this is that how lost
what Allah wants us to walk through this
life sure you know absolutely absolutely
not Eddie
absolutely marathon Allah will be either
become in chapter 2 momentum Allahu
Akbar what Allah benefits from punishing
you if you are grateful and believers
you know well I ask you by Allah what
we're experiencing Eddy is because of
the way
that we are now look at the amount of
injustice is amount of sinning amount of
you would you call that a troop pandemic
the pandemic of sin it is it is hundred
percent there is no question about it
and anyone who defy and deny this is
naive or ignorant of the pandemic the
pandemic of immorality association
partners with god almighty allah
injustice oppression injustice
oppression the way that we treat one
another as muslims you know the way that
we were trying to manipulate and abuse
one another and not observing the rights
and the etiquettes and so many things
you know i think this is a wake-up call
but only for the people of understanding
there are people who will go back to
their lifestyle to their daily routine
like nothing happened
nothing happened don't be of the loose
brothers and sisters in islam don't be
of those hey thank you very much thank
you very much for spending some time
with us and put some clarity and answer
some questions like I don't mind the
Creator Allah bless you and protect you
and your congregation there and you know
a blessed and wonderful eat it's almost
Blizzard man peak here thank you